The real question,
is that of the unity of the world of work.
This unity of the world of work,
this is what we need to work on
and what does it do
than when there is 1 movement on pensions,
it is supported by 3 out of 4 French people
and that at the time of voting,
only one French person out of 4 votes for the left,
it is precisely because this world of work,
it is now riddled with divisions,
because it is the employees
of the public against private sector employees,
because it is the
undocumented workers against
workers with papers.
And so our job is,
it's not about insisting on the differences,
is to insist on what unites the world of work
by uniting it around demands
that bring the world of work together.
And there is only like that
that we will manage to gain